they said that we would never get this
far did we hit it we didn't hit it 1.99
what are you doing you guys are all
getting tattoos Bart's gonna get the
same one on his other Shin now are we
really gonna tattoos bro what do you
mean are we really we said we would last
year are you a little [__] we're
getting fear everyone for the record I
wasn't a part of that you're part of it
now and you got to get it on your
butthole so everybody's got to get on
their butt no yeah do you really want
Barts because the thing is I already got
[__] Asian characters I'm gonna be a
whole typewriter I'm gonna be an Asian
squirrel I'm gonna be a weird stereotype
that's why girls is getting like
I have no ink on my body but I agreed to
it and I'll get the double one up extra
stupid really would you I would if
everyone was getting it oh we gotta do
it why can't you just get your butthole
tattooed you could get it on your calf
so it's different are we really gonna
get past if you're not a writer just say
so right now just [__] leave and
never come back Anthony has to get it
too I think Andy's gonna be in Indonesia
if Anthony's gone you have to sub for
his leg Anthony please